let's [ __ ] go I'm sixteen oh but whoa
no no office space anybody yeah I'm dead
so I hate now that I'm dead that's great
it's been a great [ __ ] first game
there's no sound lol people on Twitter
let me just
it didn't even allow chris said there's
no sound there's no there's not even any
sense on your [ __ ] coke they decided it
was so bad we talked about telling you
they said there's no sound they can't
hear you
who can't hear me D Warren oh there's no
sound then this is supposed to be going
on your [ __ ] you [ __ ] cat yeah but it
can't go on my [ __ ] if you're streaming
on your shoot you can't can't you turn
your mic up there you go yeah I turned
my mic on there you go you [ __ ]
tapped but you your twitch could get
mine but it's not working huh well no it
should be working now but I'm just done
up I'm getting the audio problem okay so
I'm getting now see I got a car yeah cuz
I just got a red bat
oh we're right on the edge sounds good
oh you're in the circle at lacers
there's a bright side let's see if we
can hear my audio doing here mom we got
a buggy here yeah my audios working but
my [ __ ] my audios working but my my
video is just stuck on a black screen
it's been great
damn gas way over there now I'm finally
watching you play respect hitting Chris
oh this is gonna be fun
close that door Cruz Jesus are you in
first person really can't wait to watch
that stormy Daniels interview later oh
yeah
oh so I want to check it out good oh
yeah she say if he peed on her cuz I'd
be awesome yeah that's a selection
natural selection well maybe maybe he's
got AIDS and you didn't even know it
he's just gonna [ __ ] die now he's got
enough money
he'll just blend money and the vet
checked into his veins like South Park
there you go
South Park yep ooh damn my neck just
[ __ ] cracked like a [ __ ] what
what did it sound like I'll tell you if
it was my neck yep did you die have any
other guts Jesus and the best part is
owns is like all he has on his shorts
and a backpack it's like the saddest the
saddest death I've ever seen
mmm either one all right it's not the
saddest death scene right here this is
you wear these yeah yeah somebody else
shot him well there's a plane drop just
totally get that I think if you Holden
dig dig a dude all right well that was a
on someone's shooting at me oh we're
right in front of me okay
I'm gonna get out right here and I'm
gonna snipe one of these [ __ ]
oh no he's got a sniper he's trying
it was right behind me there enough oh
no I just got hit by something now he's
on dying of course he wants to join now
hey pikachu's oh that come from behind
yeah I do but I was getting shot [ __ ]
Suarez getting shot from the other side
I'm bandaging
[ __ ] smokin god oh oh I just got hit
right in the [ __ ] back
that's just getting this on oh great
here is we get we're getting in this
that let's go
[Music]
that line is coming in
those [ __ ] are stuck in it unless
they got a [ __ ]
vehicle
at these houses see if anything's there
nothing like us hot [ __ ] did that come
from
Jesus shuffle like it's hot coming from
a crow the [ __ ] going you got a heel
up coke you're all [ __ ] up yeah I know
I know your lungs are all bleeding oh
there's a car
I like the AKM though he already got the
car though I like them six nice gets it
did you drop me use my bandages like
it's hot silence absolute silence Jesus
Christ hey Craig how was a sea of
thieves it was good for a minute we
locked up like two dudes for no reason
that was great let me know if you find a
scope if you don't want to gather got
this car but I just got a red dot
actually you know what my W minute once
that new map come there's a new map I'll
look it up there's gonna be a pig
licking it that's gonna go winds a new
map drop above G this one's just saying
it's a Serie
it's miramar it looks like it's heading
the PC first although it's a really out
on PC no it's here for PC yeah it's
still a little way away they said for
Xbox
it's bet that one's smaller right
getting that let's see we could run it I
mean okay let's run it
it robots right yeah I agree
just the two of us there got to forgot
to thank Craig for helping us so much in
this game I didn't even like everybody
talking about I didn't even get to play
I'm helping you right now I'm watching
coke with his red lungs to run across
this open field how are you gonna help
watch for me I can already see more I
could be getting shot at and I'll see
more than Craig ever does to getting
shot and does it make sense you know
where it's coming from
let's see what about those dudes right
what I'm I'm just kidding there's no
dates all right yeah
they're too buggy
yep oh there's a but there's car bike
buggy bike
they stop
you don't have a good scope for that huh
no I need one really bad I got two red
dots and a holographic punch people in
those schools
that one pass you
we can check these apartments
they've been looted like [ __ ] crazy
I'm sure and or something right I would
check it do well I said him a shock to
everybody so that means we don't do it
alright mr. Craig said I didn't lock in
I didn't even he didn't even get to land
dad it put the circle all the way around
this far away from us how do you always
die Craig consistent just hear what he
said yeah join the made it would've made
any difference he trying to make fun of
your peak school anybody sounds a hell
evolved year old yeah it's high voice I
mean you're twelve year old brother
sounds like he's 25 compared to you
you'll Pikachu Pikachu dude that is my
trash Pikachu Pikachu Pikachu s' oh [ __ ]
Pikachu wants to work out to be like you
coke the guy in tips what that's what
you said I want to work out be like coke
yeah you said that in the context this
is a joke dude Chris was here
I'll see now it's a joke now you're
embarrassed keep telling the truth
no I died grief I don't know I he's
embarrassed right
maybe Pikachu just doesn't want to like
flex for cookies afraid he's gonna see
this is non muscles oh really
where'd that you know that's so terrible
you have a red dot with the [ __ ] car
probably floss and [ __ ] with this guy
I'm you know I say me I'm not saying he
couldn't I'm just saying it just sucks
nothing
we probably got to get gone oh we
definitely got to get gone [ __ ] that
[ __ ] sucks Oh taking the Jeep I'm a
minute I'm [ __ ] bed ain't gonna
survive this oh we should have taken the
Jeep goddamnit not giving up but this is
gonna [ __ ] hurt oh boy here it comes
how far are you super [ __ ] fire this
part should be called the LOB never
ditching I'm never ditching a [ __ ]
vehicle unless it's last like three
circles this should be called [ __ ]
sewing right here just like you have to
run so far just to die
addy Warren if you press left bumper you
can zoom in a little with the gun I'm
telling this guy online
I didn't say Gavin no you know
everything swamp gobbler just killed el
general let's swap dumbass an
interesting interesting name oh [ __ ] you
might make it
Jesus s fence turns on those [ __ ]
games haha god this is so painful to
watch dude you're not gonna make it
boom yeah I'm little I'm literally right
where you are
mmm this ticket I popped it Wow
let's [ __ ] go I'm sixteen
oh but whoa what happened no no no that
was the worst yeah Gavin kill him with
the car
Milan didn't you get me well he's moving
down on you
no he's got me
you guys should go for that plane Drive
huh yeah I can't swim after this dude
this is great can you shoot him
underwater I wish you can shoot a bunch
of water that'd be so great he's
grasping on the wall you can't get up oh
he made it
oh wait but there's another guy there
and there's another guy they're both
alright another game now my shit's
working let's do it
all right let's do this
I believe in you Craig I'll get you in
here peek so I says ooh you don't
believe in them don't lie
where's everybody buy them
somebody invite that's all right I gotta
buy this
Pikachu's playing on this new computer
anyway what chick has a computer Trini
Pikachu it's good I like it yeah I got a
gigabyte did you
I can't goodbye to what the computer
yeah oh no you got uh
nothing happened mom nothing nothing
happened
nothing happened mom yeah what's
happening the [ __ ] is goin on nothin
Abby tell your mom coach says hi no no
oh she doesn't owe you doesn't want to
say that no she doesn't
she doesn't even she doesn't even want
to talk about coke anymore folks dead
and gone he's in the past any reason
that moving on moving on to Craig that
dad for like like for like a week just
so I can like whip you into shape whip
me into shape
yeah just be like all right son
and where we where we drop it
Manchin he said nobody said that nobody
said that
goddamnit let's go here where's here
let's go what are we going jumping we're
jumping where are we going I set the
marker where there's your marker what is
it though - it's your mama's house she
baked a good yes baking all them cookies
[ __ ] dude I I don't even know we're all
so [ __ ] far away from each other I
don't know where we're going you were
literally we are literally on top of
each other okay see what I mean do you
guys see what I mean Craig doesn't know
what's up what's what's down what's left
what's right for her - God literally
literally we're so far away it goes this
shouldn't needs to load load I'm still
waiting for it to load and I hear you
guys like getting guns and [ __ ] hey hope
I didn't do that
it's probably good that we get picking
the best guns is there gonna be the guns
that do the killing and you hit people
guns yeah it's like giving give all I
hear is like a charlie just like I don't
you talk let them feel let them feel
like they're having fun they're doing
something you know like that the fake
steering wheel that you put in here your
cars I have your kid [ __ ] I feel like
they're driving that's what we're doing
giving you a gun just make you feel like
you're doing something yeah yep that's
exactly so it's all jokes until Coke
starts whining get me up they hit me
Trey Craig's gonna if that ever happens
Craig's gonna be like the back one all
the way back like I'm coming I'm coming
see that's about you just try to set it
up I could never win if I mean there I'm
either saving your life or I'm wait okay
you cook they're saying you should
change your title Trey Craig Craig you
can say you would engage other people
you gotta say you change your game title
how many times have I told you that dude
you never do it oh my [ __ ] god hey
dude
even the Internet's a backlash up there
all over you about that [ __ ] you got
Craig thanks Craig Wendy never win cuz
he can't get a kill I've never seen
Craig get a kill in this game I got
really yeah hey you
your buddy Chris isn't in here right is
is Craig good at Soul Calibur Vasi so
bad and he's talking all this [ __ ] this
is like his saving grace why don't you
talk about this Holy Grail
you didn't even go to work the next day
cuz we played for like seven hours I'd
be you like yeah exactly
now didn't even come out on PlayStation
1 you racist damn Craig your boy don't
got your back time to good kind of don't
mean nice kind of I'm boy these
buildings over here cause me one of
these houses over here cuz night nothing
over there for me so yeah I gotta go to
these houses I have a pistol in 15 14
rounds how close are we to the circle
not too far
come on okay there we go I got I got
some [ __ ] here oh we got a car here well
this this place reminds me when I
[ __ ] solo chicken dinner
[ __ ] a duo duo game nice what I
remember I'd remember it oh I got a four
times
all right now now you did get most of
the kills I mean whenever I play with
you you're always way better than coke
so it's it's fun it's so lame how many
chicken dinners do you have yep hmm see
I think I have more chicken dinners than
Gabe does you're talking oh that's
charity cuz dirty was carrying you I
know dirty wasn't carrying [ __ ] I can
say I contributed I got two back-to-back
chicken dinners last night damn cousin
pronoun word yeah me son see pipe and
his buddy shadi I don't have [ __ ] I got
a [ __ ] for a mom I don't have fit I said
we go here I'm gonna [ __ ] get in this
car
I need five five six I can't even find a
shotgun oh this is weird
where is everybody here where's it now
yeah now we're now we're all right over
here I'm closest to the zone what are
you talking about I'm a [ __ ] - [ __ ] you
are not closest to the zone yeah I'm
coming towards you guys I had I was
looking for guns dude I didn't have [ __ ]
meet at that green dot that's what I'm
going did you watch that stormy Daniels
interview Pikachu's not yet it seems
like everything you love Trump and porn
stars that's like your thing whatever
Dean oh I know how much no I had but
I'll take it
oh [ __ ]
have you played pop G on your phone um I
thought Gavin I don't think I haven't no
hope late my first game I got a chicken
dinner I don't like this I can't believe
they have it they have it better
optimized than Xbox it's pretty sad
there's another UMP over here here I'm
dropping it I'm in the Hat of the house
I'm in hazard
I think I'm good for the minute
well maybe out - I'll shake it I don't
know I don't really have a secondary gun
so where where are you go I'll grab it
I'll bring it to you drop you some ammo
well here's a shoddy I'll just take this
for now I guess that's good there ammo
for it thank you son
I can't I can't do both Gavin I'm in
this house in the back here if I take
the shot II I can't take your gun yeah
you know I'll take the egg-cam
I'll take the egg-cam [ __ ] it here I'm
bringing you out I'm bringing there the
UMP where are ya
I see air swap with me damn it
hold on why does it do that
trying to switch okay yeah yeah I'll
give you I'll give you a bunch of these
you can set up drop a set amount yeah
no no that I just dropped I just dropped
that I just dropped it dropped you at
least 30 right now sitting here I don't
I got no I know what yeah yeah yeah okay
thank you
I think I already got an extended mag on
mine so if you want the extended that's
both yeah okay you learned something new
crane oh I mean I already had the
quick-draw oh so good I appreciate it
what he's saying is it's an extended
quick-draw
so it's both of them yeah I got you
where are we going
he does he got me I don't know if he
does no all right all right I'll just
start just check we're taking the car
follow me now it's got tires too late
too late
sometimes it takes her
yeah they haven't been looted let's do
it that is that cheap look like it's
been [ __ ] with no I got a silencer for
an SMG who wants it yeah I got a anybody
get another I got a flash hider no put a
silencer on there all right oh yeah
right here there you go thanks sorry
we're leaving Chris
you can't I know
Pikachu has also slept with any
politicians no
are you sure yes I came in the house I
don't see anything here you'll peel up
here cuz I should take that overlay cam
huh yeah where are you next door go oh
where are you I don't know he doesn't
know at any time where anybody's at or
what they're doing where he's gay don't
feel bad you're always mad no I'm not a
plane drop I'm laughing because oh
there's a backfire level three up here
there's another UMP Jesus dude
that's so much 13-hour 9-millimeter I
got 350 because I'm [ __ ] around
where's that which my I should switch my
scope to the scar huh there's gonna be a
lotta [ __ ] there as right is it
worth it though like those rats they
give good [ __ ] sometimes but I said
really worth it yeah but that's like the
best drop you could've got what the
ghillie suit yeah
that wasn't me that's how you know when
Craig was in there I didn't go in that
how do something wrong
pick up everything
you mean Gavin because you don't want to
fight with coke
I hear it's that it wasn't me Red's up
no no wow
white Tina I just don't want to get
[ __ ] again just don't let me get
[ __ ] again let's go up the hill you
guys Chris you know what's up yeah I
want to go I want to go up the hill I'll
get shot sound on people at perct
--kinky --kinky --kinky the what just
right up here
oh yeah that's not where I want to be I
thought this is all a hill I just want
to keep this whole line we could always
go this this building
you go take this free there's out no to
our right at 30 no sure somebody
collected it oh really
this one's not too far up here stop stop
oh [ __ ] Deb this case where the
directions oh there's a storm coming
then I'd damn it
cut my scene I say where is he huh top
of the hill there that storms gonna hit
him no and what the [ __ ] he's singing
he's got a run right into us that's
probably why he's shooting alright he's
running down
all right he's down on the street he's
taking shots at me oh I'm down he's got
a buddy back there sniping coming I'm
coming
Greg no you're gonna get you're gonna
get clap dude all right all right now
you can't no you can dad's got him guys
got him off nice Chris help will cover
fire if you can cuz I gotta get Coco
there's a guy on the street near that
tree where are you seeing them I don't
see
on the street at 340 340 I hit him he's
behind that pipeline coming out of the
the road he's right behind that I'm
hearing that for my right for my right
I'm hearing that for my right I heard
somebody over at the tree line I felt
like that [ __ ] got away um yeah I'm
coming that guy ran off under the city
the rock will move to the tree
mmm-hmm down to this rock it's off to
our left it sounded me like left yeah
I'm left I hear bite
yep just miss me
Oh what the [ __ ] hit me the [ __ ] car
[ __ ] I'm coming
oh yeah I'm gonna gonna Chris cover yeah
okay let's go
I'm like one hit though [ __ ] I didn't
see the car I saw the [ __ ] motorcycle
that sucked
jeeps run alright there's a guy oh he
got splattered holy [ __ ] I think they're
in the house is still dude [ __ ] I'm
gonna wait right by this [ __ ] tree I
gotta just wait for him to come out i if
I don't god damn it
thank you
oh my god on the end but oh I got
knocked by a car there's people in that
[ __ ] house yeah I'm dead
I do like reading diapers
there's a guy in that building I should
have died first but coke
Chris you should have you should have
taken my [ __ ] because I had some stuff
because it just wastin Gavin's hard hard
time everyone was helping it's all good
all right back each other up
hey coke I could we switch the Gavin
just like because I can't I got kicked
out of this little awesome hmm
damnit
so that guy what did he snapped you with
something coke yeah I got sides with the
car
[Music]
[Music]
that was a good run I didn't like where
we all right you out
hi buddy thanks for playing
Pikachu's never ever pikachu's you want
in here I'm still updating my pub gee
I'm sorry I suck dick you're updating
your pub gee what the [ __ ] does that
mean
look how are you still updating what are
you on a [ __ ] 1400 yeah what do you
want a modem like a baaad modem shut up
great you don't even know that's all
your time okay I know I know what it is
[ __ ]
[Music]
what else would want uh how long do you
how long you got Peaks just play what I
made before I'm ready
you guys ready Owens gotta kick you out
it's alright we left later brother
you'll back will you invite me someone
sent me an invite
take Craig you ready for April 7 April
7th + April 7th never mind
how the destiny download no what
that's next week this week I don't know
what you're talking about that what are
you talking about never mind in school
this is your birthday what am I missing
no it's not my birthday I don't know
what else what the hell is April 7th I
don't know what you're talking about
why and then you're like it's like
mystical sick no never mind
hey you're ready for doomsday what day
is it never mind never mind see you up
see you then
Oh UFC Oh who's fighting I pray I forget
I do usually watch them take a guess is
it rose and Johanna again - yeah yeah
yeah I'll check that out dude there's so
many things that could happen in a week
are we going 3-man there's so many
things I couldn't happen in a week and
you're like do you remember this one
thing like now dude I don't I don't even
know it's happening tomorrow I told you
Craig doesn't know what's left right up
and down he doesn't know what's going on
tomorrow I don't know what's going on
tomorrow it's Monday actually tomorrow I
got to take my dad's friend to get her
knee worked on my whole day is gonna be
driver man like Carter szostak Jesus
yeah Tim viewers sometimes it's nice to
be alone though and there's four there's
14 fights on UFC 223 Craig I know so
you're gonna buff up Pikachu's to join
flower I can join the flyweight division
no what the [ __ ]
you're not gonna join it now you said
you're gonna try to know it
no thank you
I get my ass beat I thought you gonna
man up you said you want to be like coke
turn you into real me
where were ya you said mansion god damn
it Craig jaegun [ __ ] bond ever
this is where we're going hmm Nova no
yeah I know you see where I got the
[ __ ] mark what did your mama's let it
out now I am or a minute away uh don't
fight with your mother son I told you
it's the [ __ ] up great see fine what's
your mom you know make me mad you're
grounded three weeks picadome oh I'm
talking to Craig you're grounded for
three oh you just leave me out so you
just use and abused me I don't know
about coke anymore I love coke no there
you go she thought you said shut the
[ __ ] you say and even more importantly
I'm playing with complaining of coke
she's gonna shut down your [ __ ]
I'm talking all that smack Pikachu so
that's your mom you got respect
cocaine's a hell of a drug well this
[ __ ] load [ __ ] man
good news guys I got shotgun I'm pretty
sure is watching Christmas gameplay and
he had two shotguns on them he did he
did let him play his game yeah it was
fun for a minute
well I was like I think he's got two
shotguns don't think that's gonna help
much they didn't want to make a comment
at the time but it was pretty funny in
retrospect and the thing is he could
alluded yeah that's what he was
[Laughter]
that's why I was funny oh I didn't know
it till I was dead I love it says game
that I was like go
it's like love Chris I love Chris and
all but that does not help your case I'm
backing you up for some Alberti you know
it's like the thing with Chris is he
plays to have fun so sometimes I think
he just doesn't he doesn't take it very
serious that's the problem he's like he
doesn't care well not me cuz I like to
win winning is fun
I got a level-3 backpack there's some
backpacks over here is not much else
though yeah when I saw that I was kind
of like wow you guys aren't gonna win
this match I was like sorry go he's
straight up running running first
running first person it was just funny I
didn't want to call him out at the
moment dual shotguns Jesus Christ
hey well the thing is like I was like I
was gonna tell him like just grab my
shakes I had a lot of good stuff on me
if he had just rained in my body but it
was too late
I had a scar in the UMP that was pretty
pretty loaded but now my problem is I
got nothing again
yes
yeah yeah that was kind of I mean when I
saw he had two shotguns I was like this
is not just not gonna end well
sorry about that but you know it was fun
while it lasted it made it made it funny
to watch in a lot of ways so that was
worth it
let's head these where did you get these
houses on the right Gavin I got a mini
houses mother [ __ ] you're running two
shotguns right now all eyes guy was a
[ __ ] shotgun on a handgun so I'm not
doing much better
let's get Craig another shotgun I would
love it the thing is like it's all fine
if you're like in a crowded environment
like school or something but it's
useless once you're out on the road yeah
definitely but I'm saying you'd have to
be close I mean they don't have a lot of
range so perfect it's right outside the
red zone we get a larger zone we're not
too far wait oh is that where is that
yeah I got nothing we got nothing to
defend ourselves with so
then we go upstairs
Oh crossbow maybe I should grab that I
would have been better if he had had two
crossbows now that then I would have
[ __ ] love life that would be the best
if you're just a dude around with you
crossbows as anybody got that come head
has anybody got yeah it's true
has anybody gotten any kills a crossbow
ever that's pretty awesome
Fox there's just nothing in these
[ __ ] places dude I got nothing
well [ __ ] I'm gonna take the crossbow
because I'd literally it's either that
or shotgun our handgun we got a car here
Lucifer this [ __ ] away yeah go here hold
on I gotta load my crossbow oh that was
me
guess keep shooting around me I'm just
gonna [ __ ] blow all you guys just
want to see if you can hear the crossbow
goers Gavin star right he's alright he's
driving the Geo I was [ __ ] with why
did I think people she was with us
dating I think I know I know I just
he's in the party
yeah I just was telling coke what you
said it stopped yelling at your mother
you only have one mom what's up down
Craig left or right this looks like it's
been open there people here [ __ ]
that's good all right find any better
guns on a crossbow loving tommy gun for
you in here I might get a second I got
it - here I got it I got what I needed I
got the what you might call it em yeah I
found a second guys
FBI that's what I really should roll
with I got a um m16 I got a suppressed
star not too mad about that - helmet
nice just both my weapons take it either
tommy gun here - I got the matrix jacket
which is pretty much the only thing I
have it all right let me know if you
guys put another one I'm ready
all right don't yell at your mom though
if you get in a fight with your mom you
can't play okay
I'm gonna drop all this 9-millimeter I
got a [ __ ] ton here
Craig take them now
I don't know drop some stuff real scope
no said boys we better get moving pretty
much like everything except for a scope
yeah let's go are you still waiting for
Pikachu he's not playing it No
yeah she was he made it
don't Jebus me best driver you ever seen
in this [ __ ] game okay it just really
doesn't [ __ ] do anything I swear to
God
[ __ ]
this is literally where we died this
last game
oh this was it was literally you saved
me right by that Shack it knows the
warehouse or you died yeah yeah where
you died yes that's true
we're in the red zone nice nice crop
nice drop
there's no people here
it looks closed I hear him coming though
there's a level 2 backpack here do you
want it
others asked are up here I should get
the scar oh [ __ ]
that shit's for real yeah up to
backpacking scope on this I'm gonna take
em 16 over the [ __ ] sky really I
wouldn't give out of mine I just swapped
it silenced anybody wants a scar there's
one over here I got mine
oh it's hairy vest military vest level
three that's good
nice okay I got a vertical foregrip for
the m416 coke if you want yeah I got
shot there's a guy on the ridge on that
yourself okay I'm inside I'm good
don't come just look for him I'm here
okay while I was here anyway what do you
want this vertical foregrip I don't take
yeah I'll take 400
where are you top on top of this
building there's not really any space to
peek out no that's fine I'm not me but I
just dropped that vertical foregrip
right here for you okay expect these
guys to come down to get in the zone yep
they're shooting at me [ __ ] where do you
swear that was right what's the number
they're trying to shoot me in the window
there South dude they're on this Ridge
they're pretty close and I don't have a
scope I can't see them anywhere I'm
looking at 175 190 I don't see anybody
oh no but we're right in the zone they
got a [ __ ] move you know I'm gonna
just stay down here and keep them keep
us keep these doors oh I see him I see
him
so he's 210 behind this tree 210 okay
thank you
yep he's running that field [ __ ]
[ __ ]
there's two of them there's another one
behind him I hit him I hit the one
running yep run [ __ ]
he's still shooting back at me somebody
is somebody that far Adebisi what's he
saying dude all the way back there
sure song
say you Gavin yeah I'm kidding I'm
coming out I can't I can't get on from
this far that circles on alright we got
a vehicle I said we beat them here those
guys are gonna try and get there all
right I'm like okay all right get there
all right I'm down for that
all right already
oh there's a drop straight ahead of us
too
I wonder what the [ __ ] he was shooting
from that far away I don't know but I
saw his muzzle flashes definitely him
okay it hit me but now I didn't hit me I
threw his [ __ ] he's [ __ ] shoot
that's up maybe so all right oh yeah
coming on the car
oh just out going keep going keep going
keep going
walk Gregg's - they got me in the car
[ __ ] cuz we were out of it no no I
jumped back in they got me in the car
I peeked out I shot and then I stayed
back in and then I was in there right as
we passed them they were shooting me
from behind I think that I was in the
backseat they're all [ __ ] we're able to
company
thanks for the help Pikachu Nepal that's
gonna flip it huh no I'm doing what I
can you get that download you know it's
downloaded and ready
did you get that download
yeah
was that English got no [ __ ] skills
hopefully this hasn't been looted I
could get a 4-time that you [ __ ]
fantastic I only had a two time I hit
that first dude on the [ __ ] second
sucked there is he's coming in the same
door as you someone jumped feel like
somebody just jumped was that you nice
yep no I got an m16 you can take it
I do need a site we get it Craig you
vape just joking I got my new vapes does
it make a crackling sound yeah
oh that is faith in Gavin I hate crates
so much ever get in this game in the
what month that I've been had it you
didn't even want to play this game for a
month you know how much convincing it
took Jesus and you know what's funny
about that is it took the convincing you
guys had to jump on me and I'll still
have more chicken dinners than you ever
will have it you're good at first person
shooting game so I agree you know you're
not gonna be good at I have I have here
I'll drop it
25 stats for you but both my weapons
take it at 90 yep
my Run button will work
Jesus Christ that's the worst times to
not work swear too [ __ ] bad just
their Microsoft Store by you coke no
there's a guy up this Ridge 2:05 what
happened control are supposed to
you see him
okay he's gonna be coming up I may have
his ID may have draw his attention I'm
gonna try running under this tree
[ __ ] wrong guy
alright yep he's up here yep he's taking
shots at me same position as Anse moving
in I got to move up this Ridge Gavin so
good
yeah that's our number left Frank nope
bottom Hill
yep [ __ ] storm yeah I can't run I
can't [ __ ] run oh my god Xbox KITT
rim
[Applause]
that's such fix the worst [ __ ] time
to do that [ __ ] dude I swear to God
every [ __ ] time do you have an old
controller have you just tried switching
back to your older controller no it's
the elite so yeah but I'm saying like if
you're given all their controller I
guess you got that one hood see sense
let's invite me with you
I got one more yeah this is a smell
again this is my last game you haven't
even started one yeah I have now I'm
trying to peek at you seven I did join
up
I eat this let me go make some branched
chain amino acids real quick
okay how do you make those in a lab well
I guess I'll never know
when's your birthday Craig sometime in
the future okay I'm sure birthday
Pikachu it's in July I were not that far
yeah my birthday's coming up I don't
like that it's pretty disgusting luckily
in there you look like you're 15 so I'll
be good for another cup hangers all
right same till he's in a mansion
somebody set man someone put a marker
hello do lumberyard I'm going good prank
what are you doing
fallin cabin what do you mean what am i
doing
really oh yeah I'm gonna get to it right
behind Gavin
I don't think I'm a choice I'm gonna
land on this Hill melton near each other
Gavin are you whispering sleepy no I'm
just kidding oh that makes even less
sense I mean no I mean no my brother's
asleep no no no no not even worried yeah
just it's not worth now worth him and
getting in depth with him on anything
shut up Craig he just makes up stuff my
brother is sleeping
I mean I'm sleeping I mean I have to be
quiet it makes sense coming from so much
shooting right up top here cover me
I'm shooting at him I got in a camp I'm
gonna spray this [ __ ] brain all
over the street yeah I'm coming up [ __ ]
I don't have that many bullets and I
can't see what I got
nice I don't get them nice
I'll probably have boyfriends around
where was that
he's coming around back that's me watch
out pick up Pikachu get back yeah
he's dead
I'm out of [ __ ] animal he's dead
did he have anything nothing now he's
trying to punch us I know just try to
see [ __ ] I took all my ammo UMP over
here too I still need a lot of [ __ ] I
can use that Irene the zone yes we are
good [ __ ] where were those helmets and
thing to suck out no boy was to opera
down here it's up top down I literally
just told you where it is
he doesn't know what's up what's down no
all right oh I found a UMP
you take the best coke
I didn't take a mess
backpack and needed backpack I found the
helmet I don't see the vest and I don't
have me some more ammo oh it's on the
ground okay sorry I missed it
[ __ ] we've always hit prison okay let's
go I'm coming [ __ ] [ __ ] up
oh do we have one we got EMP I got a red
dot in the car what it cooks I got a red
dot
Oh red dot that's it I don't think many
people dropped here I actually think we
got an advantage because it went it went
uh even lost military base yeah yeah if
anything there might be people behind us
mm-hmm
well that's where those two people came
I'm surprised I got a kill I did damage
on that guy just ran out of ammo sucked
uh-huh I didn't want you to die I didn't
want you to die right then on the wait
so I had a chance there's anyone here at
prison I don't think so I am yeah I
wouldn't say I would think somebody
would be here right now but never say
never you know no way the night plane
fell or wipe yeah well I would have me
yeah
computing
BMP okay you okay Kevin oh jesus here we
go I was talking to my brother but yeah
Oh what was that great hey I was talking
about his brother lucky Craig yeah
exactly
he that person he's a person Pikachu
Jesus no he's another person there I
[ __ ] okay I got a shotgun ooh level
three vast extended man I'll take both
of those I still have five five six
anybody seized a bunch of it got level
two helmet in here if anybody wants it
okay and there's a level two best in
this house okay hey just picked up a two
times scope you guys need it I'll give
it to you all that one of the other guys
have it yeah you get a car don't you
should want that [ __ ] yeah frag grenade
you guys see any politics let me know
got a four time I got to tell any
backpacks uh I didn't see any backpacks
yeah if anybody finds a t56 oh I [ __ ]
have no ammo for my [ __ ]
what was that correct okay okay you know
I love you
he's your brother as annoying as your Z
way more chill I don't know he's a
little kid so as opposed to you doing
that's it dude you might play this game
I'll kill you I'll [ __ ] kill you
first but I've done it before I'll do it
again
should I keep it tommy gun or pick up
the UMP or keep the UMP UMP I think you
know what keep the car
if you don't like the [ __ ] car I'll
take it we have seven bullets I'll take
it I'll trade you
I'll try to UMP now I already have UMP
but yeah I'll give one of the boys the
car they're better at sniping I'll give
you I'll give you an AKM okay for it
we're yeah didn't come to you I don't
have any [ __ ] five five six goddammit
goddammit let me good mm-hmm say one
more time P could you say it one more
time oh okay take it one more ticket
okay coming
where are you Marsha it oh my god I
can't [ __ ] run we check all these
yeah they're pretty much run through
then you guys check the house up in the
hell are we going to the rap break or
the once the way right just we might be
able to hit Madison may be gutsy but I
think we might be able to now you want a
hit man [ __ ]
well the flight path no what are you
talking about
plane coming dude that door almost [ __ ]
so now Hannah's on I got an eight-time
scope for somebody not for me
well I got a car so does gaff I will
hold up in this [ __ ] yeah and I'm
trying to run into the house you not
want the eight times go
I'll keep it then now all right fair
enough just trying to be helpful y'all
doors not open near the mansion over
there [ __ ] I have not found any five
five six dude this is ridiculous
beds own careful or suppressor for the
SMG yes thank you do you have two of
them on a double fist
[ __ ] damn should I should I keep this
AKM oh you got some okay cool I'll grab
that we're at which house if you guys
see 9-millimeter I see a Gavin I see you
I got a sit-down the nine mil okay I'm
coming down thank you
I definitely mean I got a little bit but
from my car
this is driving me [ __ ] a wall right
now oh my god I'm moving I'm moving
towards these first as I'm moving so
[ __ ] slow
oMG with Eric Coke and a fun funny dude
named Craig and then play with Gavin are
you just talking to yourself yeah that
sounds pretty cool
no I'm something to my brother Gavin
Craig you have a brother Greg no they
don't
not yet he's probably going to master we
could always hit these big houses up top
it's all right here
where'd you guys go - did you guys take
off on the motorcycle Craig are you
listening at all thinking she was trying
to distract them alright okay I'm good
I'm coming still there Pikachu
wait no hey [ __ ] and oh no don't
say that always [ __ ] with me it's that
s12 Oh
yeah [ __ ] with me every [ __ ] time
right now I'm checking these houses oh
that's us it's us
okay you drive peeks I hear another
motorcycle yeah where does it coming
this doors open there's shots
she'll be shiny I'm gonna try and hit
them what was that shot coming from
that's me
there's a guy at mansion hit him
he's 280 right along that house you know
I wanna [ __ ] do eight times
he's gonna shoot out there to shoot out
it sucked up something [ __ ] this guy in
the window there's a DP 29 that good how
is that not getting its strong I think
it's a drop-off right it's gotta be
drop-off
red dot side over here holograph
holographic I don't need any five five
six is that you Pikachu yeah
who is that
nice means meets me who wants my rouse I
can give you some where's Gavin oh there
you are
okay hold up there's still a ton of guys
are matching so where did the zone move
hey I can give you some more rod
mansions that yeah let's hit this we got
a bike let's hit this right over here
what are we hitting bleating yeah
you can actually fit three people on
this bike I don't come up with you Gavin
something's pulling up on us where
sounded sounded like you I don't know if
it's worth shooting
well you can't shoot off the back of a
motorcycle
you can't have your pistol I think all
right these guys were over here
was a jeep here
get in my kit I'll go on it an octave
thanks is that there's a mecca here yep
ain't just somebody upstairs is there I
mean I was thinking there's one that's
usually two here on the terrace I'm
alone oh I'll go first
oh Jesus Christ arty Jesus there's ways
to check it without [ __ ] just running
in there yeah I know I know
all right I don't see anybody else in
here but might be in the next building
yeah this building's open this
building's open he's on the bottom floor
did you guys are going this building but
you think that had a star that I just
making sure those there's no how much
five five six yeah there's his buddy I
got his buddy I got his buddy
he's dead where where yeah he's upstairs
in this building and he's got a five six
nice bro got [ __ ] ton of five five six
he's got four times I'll grab that too
there's a scar there's a scar over here
I got the four times and and the eight
times if you want one
I'll take okay give me the eight I don't
know I gotta be honest I don't know how
that dude didn't get one Jimmy Jimmy
dude eight times out here come here I
got it here I'm dropping it right here
it's right down on the ground
I don't know how that I didn't get
didn't get a shot off no one's gonna
take this car where's the eight times
right here right here I'm downstairs I'm
in the middle right here
oh oh right here right here
did everybody take everybody take all
the five I got it five five six I got
here I'll give you so my good
here take I don't there there's there
there here
how much is how much is 74 but now it's
not good enough for you I'm just trying
to [ __ ] I'll grab it okay I'm gonna
take it someone take this car start
poking around where's that where's that
huh who you shootin house me all right
left
oh there's a guy yeah he ran around on
our left
is he dead dead
hey we have a jeep we have a GP of Iowa
we have a Jeep over J now [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that we're going on site oh he got me
[ __ ] good tag they got buddies yet a
Gardens vent the car the hole just uh
what's the direction here smoke there's
guys behind us dude I see one should I
hit one on the right doing what I gotta
get that when I get this Jeep let's go
let's go let's go let's go I got to go
we got to go okay
it's not moving [ __ ] there's no gas Go
Go Go we gotta run [ __ ] this [ __ ] up
dude I need to get healthy
I can give you a first thing in that got
it like that it I just I just got to get
out of here for a second okay yep I hear
that but I got a car's trying to run
wall yeah [ __ ] that was close
yeah it was I was disgustingly close
[ __ ] wrong dude
Oh where's that coming from that behind
us huh
oh [ __ ] getting inside yeah I gotta go
what are the coordinates on that car
yeah I'm in this [ __ ]
was that anybody else have any five five
six I could get rid of yeah I got a ton
Yeah right there I'm entering the house
no no I got it I got it
here I got 107 no I don't need it yeah
that's cool that's perfect I'll give me
yeah if you want to thanks Pikachu yeah
I dropped it on upstairs [ __ ] I don't
know that should be good Oh
two times scope I choose this door open
Pikachu she's Christ you have any
manners okay anyone has any other scopes
let me know
I got it two times if you want it I'll
take it look okay it sounds like it's
coming off you are southwest come on
down
I'm epic okay Northwest where you where
are you hearing it where is it coming
from the Northwest Ohio enough room
Jesus Christ straight in front of us I
say they come let him get home we gotta
move we gotta move soon we will be well
but we're close I see him on the ridge
line yep
where's that one number about 3:45 he's
look out toward that house up there
going to that house up there I think at
the 340 mark yeah I can drop some for
you I just 47 over here where I'm at
where are these dudes
how are those people still shooting is
there one in that there's one in that
house hold on hold on I hit one near the
house think he'd laid down get ready to
go to the zone here okay yeah that we
gotta go yeah bless my shot it I'm down
for SKS are you [ __ ] kidding me man
no don't don't [ __ ] with it easy
there's a guy right in front of you
[ __ ] I couldn't get in the zone just go
peek speaks go toward Gavin if you can
get over there I'm dead damn it let's
try to get this ghillie suit yeah you
can't dude one of the circles is small
you just got a run-in bro
you can't tell us but then I was living
that way you can't stop for a ghillie
suit damn I was a good run to do it yeah
that's all you go yeah you were so
[ __ ] that you had that so good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]